and welcome to this video playing
Miranda marando okay denmark ternational
master pad too Wow pad where yo you Jana
or I'm screwed the sub terribly small
under ok let's see what we got from the
Queens gambit or Bishop before maybe
nope yeah well this is also possible
going to hedgehog waters hedgehog what
is this is probably something we had run
ok so I'm playing the line that I have
some experience in this is actually a
setup that I like very much for white
especially if black plays exactly like
she is doing here rook t1 it's good on
the default and after possible night c5
this always nice d3 looming so trying to
cover the d3 scram ok so we get this
fairly typical situation here white
gaining lots of space on the the King
side let's see how black is going to be
okay she's aiming for a queen trade um
the question is no not really I don't
need to trade myself i can actually let
her take that's probably even even
better how would you continue in this
position if however is really bad here
difficult would like to move any of the
pawns maybe Bishop e3 this is very often
a good idea intending Bishop takes you
five now that was quickly played 6 i'm
wondering if maybe g6 is a possibility
takes takes knight takes Bishop c5 and
night x is six possible okay all right
let's not overthink matters here okay
I'm going to do this creating i'm
relatively one-sided position where the
b 6 a-6 pawn this week there is 94 yeah
night a for here is this winning a pawn
already be five or Knight b6 still
possible
let's take first I maybe night a four
she's got she's got rookie to this was
badly played okay yeah Brooke takes the
eight was really nonsense okay anyway I
need to continue I still have slight
slight chances here for um for a small
advantage based on the fact that the
pawns on dark squares so night here the
other light should go to d3 keep okay
now i have f5
if I've is very questionable coming
coming to d5 now yeah i guess the check
or a 5v5 is also very good takes Knight
a form getting the pawn down not sure
both them both very promising 95 was
also attractive but takes Knight a force
even better I think now I wondering what
is she thinking about like must take
otherwise I take b6 and it's simply over
yeah that's important I shouldn't
shouldn't take care of the night is
strapped down chal eet I need to just go
back no probably
not sure maybe King g4 and time whining
and f6 to continue again and pulling on
the dark squared sense curious
not one hundred percent sure if this was
right no it wasn't it sucked sucked
swank'd myself here that's great hey how
stupid can you play this was really
really low-tech amazing c5 this was
really amazing Lee mistimed not easy
now it was all so stupid ma'am that's
not does not spoil much Gras our third
game drown I'm coming channel I cannot
not win by a c5 ah this was so terribly
played by both I mean what she did was
really bad but c5 is oh man maybe maybe
c5 in itself wasn't no she's screwing up
the moves ah how can I stop this I want
to look at the game so c5 so maybe c5
was winning but I need to do some yeah
here f6 here f6 this wins the H Paul
check yeah this this is winning indeed
because I get the H porn and then I'm
winning easily with the pawn promoting
this this was a really great con sus
it's still winning I don't believe that
and now the evil Scott is going down
okay this is maybe a slightly better
chance still gaining that's it this is
at all and what a shame what a shame
yeah after move like a five you
absolutely must win the game if I've is
a gross positional error absolutely
terrible it gets another poll on dark
squares and weakens f5 and enter and d5
especially after that white is very
close to winning and here after that I
am winning but I play it really terribly
after just so can we both probably
deserve a loss and scamming
95 also when CM just just winning
winning in the house okay I probably
shouldn't play right after dinner yeah
this does not help okay thanks for
watching